I've got skin issues skin issues I've
got skin issues that's the news
skin issues psoriasis is getting better
but I've got some precancerous regions
i'ma face to be really good at music
choice to enjoy the songs we talk about
the juicy spot on your head though yeah
well she goes I only had that I go well
no who's she she's a dermatologist you
know her first name is Dixie she's
called doc she's good-looking
she says good-looking as a 59 year old
woman gets she's 60 she's as
good-looking as a 50 dr. dick a ditchy a
beautiful woman oh yeah
oh God tall Tomcat yeah Tom cart smarts
at a fat tits on the front she's in a
lab coat and I'm not gonna answer that
question she's a doctor
lab coat trench coat sweat suit joggers
by the way attitude by the way there's
nothing like when a gal is dressed you
know like a business lady but she can't
hold back at her hubby I mean like a
fool no bow bro it's like a wave pool
right nothing just dying my bad there's
this girl you know she go I just had
that because when I go to work I have to
de-stress I just had to cover everything
up because otherwise and she was just
amazing it's that joke there's just
spilling over the table you know in the
old Brennan's joke about when you see a
woman who's really stacked and it's like
if that was a building that be unsafe
like radicular [ __ ] is going on here she
but she's just she's got these big blue
eyes Oh what's this oops I need some
skin grafts now well I get I got a strip
down to my underwear by the way hopeful
more do you think that I'm not my job I
got two nurses in there if you then
they're all cute baby nurses first sang
nurses do do this a nurses wink kick
rocks
I don't but I'll tell you their notices
the doctor let dr. dick over to check
out these anal warts
I don't have anal warts that's what you
told me what not all your sayings in the
story that's not sexy you tell me you
didn't go train awards don't say that
stuff because all right it'll catch
it'll catch fire all right
Kellen has anal warts already and you
don't we're already [ __ ] I've never
had anal warts we're gonna we're gonna
edit that out because no amount of [ __ ]
never gonna amount of [ __ ] I'll get no
you know that's going live with it
so you get that just don't smile off the
top your head so I get this so I go to
her and I go I got this spot she goes
hmm
first he looks at my back scuse me yeah
that's that's that's just probably
whatever freezes that off and then she
goes mmm
she looks at my head cuz yeah I don't
like that we're gonna freeze it off now
if if it comes back
yup four weeks we got to go do a biopsy
and and cut into it otherwise I'm fine
yes why did you ever Sunday oh it's
being a white kid growing up in Saudi
Arabia Pakistan Lebanon Greece all those
sunny places and mommy never put we
didn't have some black box block or
black or black back in back in 90s
unblocker blonde in the 1920s you didn't
have somebody you just were allowed to
go out in the Sun and get burned as [ __ ]
and that was that's it I know that's
what it is she'll tell you the doctor oh
and by extra juicy right now by the way
syrup for anybody who has doesn't have
skin like Brennan who's supposed to be a
white guy for anybody doesn't have that
skin when you wear a t-shirt and then
you wash it couple times it's like and
you go out in the Sun your t-shirt is
basically like having a four sunblock on
it blocks the Sun like if you'd be like
wearing stuff or sunblock dr. dick said
yeah I've heard this from three doctors
we'd in fact this is back you're getting
old sure yes you're getting a farmer's
tan some boys not so sure it's all the
time those stay with the pharma Stan you
still get any Sun this is [ __ ]
no you know people want to tan when
super sunny out yeah you know you know
when it's cloudy you're still getting
rise there are all kinds of ways oh hey
you hose grease up your ass you can do
all that with the clouds
hey you hose grease up your ass I'm
aggressive this morning about four you
know hordes great I know that that
podcast see honey that guy that poor guy
he washed I he looks like the type you
have that same tank top for many of
years yeah he's watched it many times
nothing in helping roam now now why did
he get Florida was it was he
beeping with his arms folded but I like
that you know huh
I really had a some sort of satchel on I
would assume
uh-huh some sort of satchel that did
that a satchel yeah yeah now here's the
thing about having a female
dermatologist if you did have warts on
your dick
and rewards rum or on your rum you can't
go to your female dermatologist
you can't go hey look at my butt right
you should do that you have to have a
guy I'd have to have a guy I'm going all
the girl all day what all day what a
mean girl you up I hey are you doing
good looking 59 year old here's my let
me peel my [ __ ] so you can take the
anal warts off my my rim or boy hey bro
with the [ __ ] bratwurst finger pass
at least dude oh no I know it you can't
trap you now we figure this out Lester I
don't stay here yeah of course you want
a man to do no if I had if I had anal
warts god forbid I would I would want a
man I'm not gonna make a woman look at
my first fight I wanna make a woman look
at my [ __ ]
a second of all who do it bro do it I
don't give a [ __ ] you [ __ ] baby your
legs up like this well it's rude to have
a woman look at it especially I
distinguish much rather have a woman you
would yeah tell dr. dick I need
something looked at don't call her dr.
day
what's her yeah dr. dick bro and her
first name is Dixie she's friends called
dick all right dr. dick hey I was I
heard a lot of talked about you've heard
of a Brazilian wax right you know you
can get up balls in but that's the most
common thing that guys do they get balls
and but yeah balls and bust okay girl
gets all the time and she goes yeah
that's my girl they ripped the stuff
here take the hair off your butt what in
the taint to the [ __ ] come on dude
now I know right sounds super pay put
how I think though
let's Sanatana Terry yeah sometimes I'll
take my undies off mic Pro you're too
old for you you got your back oh you're
bad why I'm too old to have [ __ ] Street
yeah I'll stick my ass right in the sink
and clean it off I've seen you do that I
got just cuz I got a clean whistle
though just discussed my whistle is
clean have you ever thought about doing
the
wacks sure haven't it hurt sure haven't
what I will do is I'm getting all fours
but I'll take is there's on the number
two guard on the old that's better
and I'll just I'll just trim it down
that's a bad idea you got a man scape a
little bit yeah or you just like my dad
that probably in in the history has
dingleberries from the history of his
life has never done anything like that
you didn't ever dad has dingleberries
that heard the Beatles live is correct
sir that's correct he just dis no [ __ ]
he's never never shaved anything between
his legs my problem is [ __ ] or mother
that's everyone though that's that's
that's everyone
yeah I remember I was in my dad would
you know I would work out I wouldn't be
in the in the gym at Greenwood Village
my dad just everyone that just bushes an
area huge bushes huge I'm like dude
first of all you want to trim it down so
your shaft looks longer this yes fellas
right and then then that's like you get
the tail the duck tail at the back yeah
get out the top I don't want any now
it's to Schaick it down he's don't
they're too comfortable if they yeah
you're not a hairy guy though I'm not a
real hairy guy no but I would like a
little down here we're all gonna get
hair yeah just a matter of time bro yeah
yeah there's there is I I will say this
when I first came to Los Angeles
I dated a beautiful girl she was just
nothing short of beautiful and she was
so hairy she was so hairy it was like a
bear's paw down there I was like you
there are I kidding what's with your
bears Paul and I'm not joking I go and I
said to my buddy I don't know how to
tell her and my buddy said there he said
he'll I'll tell my girlfriend she knows
her and then she told her girlfriend and
her girlfriend girls you know she's just
a total earth-mother so no no well no
well you may be an earth mother but I
don't want to put my dong in in a bear
Paul
no you know why because of it if they're
hairy down there remind you of a dude
like dudes are hairy down they don't see
like I agree look up the word mall mall
em aw I think that's what you would call
just a massive hair patch I might be
wrong really a gigantic Wolfhound
with a fearful giant mall
the guy so you know what it's a wolf
mouth
a wolf now that makes sense that's a
good reference right
um or she had a giant mall cuz that's
what it looked like the mouth is pink
you know what no matter how hot there
that something I can't put up I couldn't
put up with it dude
they're certainly like I'm such a visual
person if they're if that's off and she
was my big girl amazingly beautiful and
so uh you don't need good say something
like that was too young to do it I even
canal I'd be embarrassed to do it I know
I don't hurt anybody's feelings to be
weird about it but I would have been you
know that's what those are those things
look it's like sometimes you'll be in
your history of your relationships I'm
sure you've been on dates and gotten
together with a girl who has whose
breath smells like an open grave ooh
right and you're not gonna tell her but
you should tell her for her lip for her
sake I had I've had three experiences
get gum though you know I'm still like
people have clocked in atomic I won't
say the name and you just talked I was
like how do you not taste the [ __ ]
coming out of your mouth how do you not
taste the [ __ ] open grave that you're
spinning right now yes I know with girls
it's even worse though but I guess if
you like I'm not thinking carries
minutes [ __ ] you if you can't imagine
yeah all right but Altos is a problem
yeah some people have that like that or
some people just smell like [ __ ] and if
you have like you know if you have your
[ __ ] Altoids you like dude you want
to MIT like yeah it'd be like if your
breath stunk right and I'd like dude
your breath smelled like [ __ ] you want
to MIT yeah that's the way to like kill
it with human a little bit yeah well
like a [ __ ] omelet no I'm saying I was I
was on set yesterday and I was looking
at my phone and I just and a guy who was
working he was an electrical guy good
guy but big big guy I just I just
smelled a sour I just was like that man
you smell like sour sour milk like just
really honestly just hey man you smell
like these our done worse how about that
I was getting my hair cut today and the
barbershop always go to it's all
Mexicans only makes them barbers and
everyone's like tired I'm there early in
the morning after you're done working
out I go there and there's a line I want
this one guy specifically I've always go
to this guy
I sit down and the news like he's like
Oh what do you want you know I'm like oh
the usual dude and he does this thing or
these get ready to start and on the TV
there's like some horrible news of this
drunk driver who hit this pregnant
mother the mom died it's like the worst
news you've ever seen yeah and I just
hear the my barber go god damn oh yeah I
know [ __ ] right can we turn that off
like I sound like a day goes no no it's
on a farm
no someone farted like he's the head
guys like so much far didn't it says it
loud and I'm like looking and they're
all like they're all built exactly the
same like five six five seven perish a
thick Mexican a [ __ ] like you tell so
and had chorizo this morning and what am
i farted and it ruined the entire
morning like he's like nah oh I know ray
goes now man some farted in here I was
like and then it crept to me I was like
well that's it sir I could start
laughing I don't know why they weren't
laughing hey just a story amazing I went
well that's it is that thick thick
[ __ ] war as smaug fart
like it was the worst man my son
Everett but the thing it is not like Oh
bro I'm going to Mir we're all just
sitting in it just basking in this
[ __ ] and ah you can't not see what a
little hard for ya you can't say you
can't not saying called you I start I go
oh my god dude who does that and then
the black guy gets here goes
[ __ ]
I just start shaking his head I was like
damn alright man my son I went to that
movie alpha with my son and it's it's
ballin in a fake language so I keep
having to tell my someone what the
subtitles are saying and it's all about
a rite of passage for a boy a young man
who loses track of his it's caveman days
he loses track it's actually a good
movie of his tribe and has to make its
way back home and almost dies in the
process but it's a really good movie
about man it's good for kids you know
it's about sure rites of passage facing
your fears and all that and I'm
explaining it to my seven-year-old son
and it's kind of a bonding moment for me
and my son I'm going to see he's
teaching
had a hunt and he's afraid but he's
saying that you're talking about the
yeah well my concern goes this is how I
son whispers what's he saying I
understand what's going on like and now
myself I gotta go hey it's cute down up
yeah and my son is sitting like this in
the hotel and he would just he was
floating air biscuits that would bar he
was farting I'm talking about he'll get
out of his seven-year-old ass that would
that would clear down stop lax flight is
the word patterns like I was like and I
go you got to stop farting and he goes
no I can't I can't and the people behind
me it was such a disaster I go do you
have to poo I'll take care of I goes no
I don't have to poop really loud F he
just kept farting it was a disaster
terrible for everyone else there yeah
yeah yeah yeah dropping air biscuits as
they say dude yeah you gotta float an
air biscuit
dude you're me a little Ganzi next week
I'll be gone you're be gone oh my god
doing doing my thing go into an art I'll
be acting you'll be doing our York City
I'll be seeing Duff David off Jimmy
Burke John people your people because
you'll be out there for like six days
yeah yeah not therefore one one one
night maybe I'll see you on Wednesday
depending one happy right cuz you leave
this week yeah you gonna be there
Wednesday
yeah next Wednesday I get in I don't
know you should all you should you
should I shoot just that night I'm doing
the watch what happens live in any
killing show they don't get oh I'm gonna
lock it off we could broadcast New York
don't know where we do about there's no
video doing your podcast we get video
set it up baby yeah you're on set we
just roll any yeah we like to stroll and
eat what am I going that I have a
[ __ ] rest cafe sick ladies yeah
shout out to Thomas Fiona he's an MMA
fan nice is he's Greek but his name is
Thomas
so my strange Tomas Tomas Tomas Jorge
the different words different names in
different languages which are cool I can
be a little upset at me I've been to
burring everywhere my car's in the shop
and I know why no I know why it's not
cuz is his impossible Porsche
is it's not because it's in the shop
because of the engine it's because he's
getting gold rims don't ducks get a new
pair of K gold rims to make it even
worse that car that car is the world I
saw you you know yeah I saw you I
pretended I didn't yep I meet you I
pulled I got you I see that you know
what finna know you know that's the
street my house is I know you saw me me
yeah but you were you're a gone so I'm
not gonna speed up oh my god miss my
puss we're sorry yeah did you call me
Hey oh there's Brian I had an impulse
for whatever reason to call like I was
gonna be like I see what are you doing
Oh gotcha
I just saw you I know it's and I just
saw you near them hey look what a
coincidence I'm on your street gotcha
dude how about that restaurant we go to
all the time and when we're in the
middle of a deep companies try to figure
stuff out yes how you guys doing
combo killer Benny God Brennan a buck in
an inner tube combo he does this every
time every time yeah we're in a middle
of conversation so he what he listens
it's an Italian restaurant is this
Italian restaurant he's a grown man this
grown with you talking he comes over hey
you know I have a question for you yeah
hey what do you guys think about the you
know 500 literally in the middle of a
God literally well I - I like having a
very serious conversation about
something who does that who [ __ ] does
that how do you not read you know I hear
you sorry buddy I hear your Chin's
trying to come to Seattle because he
wants to fish doing this [ __ ] I'm doing
shows there he just wants to fish I want
see your show to you man all right bro
don't you also want to kill some fish
yeah fishing I heard is really good
there you all tuned efficient for my
like in China be honest why you so into
fish and bro yeah yeah I'm into catch
and cook now what do you mean the
Shanina you mean there's a bunch of
videos on YouTube these guys have tons
of subscribers they just go fishing they
film it they catch their fish they kill
it mmm they got it they clean it and
they cook it and they eat it right there
oh they eat it on the boat on the boat
on the surf
I'm on the beach and your favorite
hearts is it when they KITT and then I
got it and there's all the blood and
stuff I'm not gonna lie that's that's
trying to figure to help be seriously
though cleaning fish that you like that
feel of it huh I can actually take out a
trout's guts in one swoop but you can oh
my boy isn't the thing it's very
interesting that's what he's into I can
take out a trout's guts in one so what's
the biggest fish you've caught chin in
other words how many men have you killed
the biggest fish was probably a 35 pound
catfish Wow and Lake Havasu of all
places
now you can catch catfish with your
hands yeah yeah you get deep in noodling
otherwise their tentacles gonna get you
I've seen the stingers we caught much
fishing
nope they don't I don't know yeah it's
something like you're a shitty word
fishing I know there's something like
them swamp mud there's a show Noodlers
they call Noodlers you've done that gen
nah dude we should you film us noodling
I put there's some new little resistance
is shown right they wanna do it sort of
[ __ ] a block LaVon not man you do it
like the new lurgy
but the problem is gonna walk around the
swamp for the catfish are scared well
who else you know who else they share
them swamp grounds with the old croc a
dealer does mm-hmm put your put your
hand in my mouth yeah that's if you
feelin froggy
once you put your hand down my face
little problem problemo see ya cuz that
that's that time you got to get
elbow-deep these [ __ ] let me
see the other one let me see that one
that those two guys know you're being
catfished that's a huge that's a whale
shark but uh okay me we have a male
shark that's not a cat bro that's a
giant catfish that's also photoshopped
I don't think it is I think they are
that no they get big I feel like is
there a place you can go uh probably not
la where can you go you know noodle this
that you gotta go to the what midday
Hannah you got a grin out of the south
so I'll just hurry I think the saralyn's
yeah down down working down an alligator
territory I think see I'm not trying to
get it [ __ ] neck deep into the water
like that [ __ ]
chin will you be down to do this
finally kid go noodling hell yeah yeah I
bet you would
so you got Texas Oklahoma Georgia okay
you know Texas all the time
Oklahoma
in there yeah but this the prom though
we're newbies right we're amateurs we're
the JV squad yeah we are put our [ __ ]
hands down that thing's grill yeah they
sting you need you need a guide
no they sting you they'll sting oh yeah
they're the thing that's their face
those whiskers sting you oh that's what
we should do and film it find the kid go
noodling and chim dies we need to I
don't know just an accident
my buddy my buddy out he goes headfirst
in this giant catfish
you know our boy John Brenkus yeah John
was like you know this year I'm gonna do
no dangerous sports I'm not gonna get
hurt he's on all courses yeah he gets
knocked out then he's on a boat
yeah slips off and breaks his back yep
Jesus she's cute that's a cute hillbilly
why is the hillbilly one those jean
shorts aren't cut like just a very shame
suit I appreciate you know I love the
Joe Dirt look in a girl so the thing I
like that Joe Dirt vibe so like the
short cut short then the top yep like
her you might drink Budweiser mm-hmm my
yeah I'm not might drive a Camaro she's
a tomboy - dude look at these this is
what we need to get into dude I feel
like we need new hobbies like what's
your hobby right now
just [ __ ] street fighting right and I
see it not really right yeah I'm into
parkour and dicks we're into the same
stuff Wow okay so why do I get into
noodling bro
I like why can't noodling be our thing
we don't live in the states where you
can do it Oklahoma I got money we can
travel I don't know if we're gonna
travel to go we're not you and I are not
gonna take two planes and [ __ ] car
and a rental car bro I'm telling you so
hit us up and make it easy like remember
well you and I want to do the finally
kids Spartan Race and he bunch of
[ __ ] never got around to well you and
I if I hope you'll do this with me we
should in October noodle we can do two
things in October you and I can go
noodling no we need three things we can
do these things
one weekend noodle all right but I'm in
Oklahoma well no - we can go fly
privately to Bordeaux and stay at a
chateau and drink the best one in the
world lead the best food in the world
oh that's all free of charge for us okay
wait free of charge you see my skeptoid
what are you gonna do bro
Jack man up for my feelings just gotta
talk about fighting the whole time and
take your shirt off but it's not
fighting there's a lot of questions you
want answer and then they talk about the
height and weights of men that's exactly
right
other than that it's my life and great
wine and eat great food that that's the
that's the second thing that we can do
and the third verse - I made - right now
the third thing we can do and it can be
televised is we can do an episode of
meat-eater with Steve Rinella kill elk
in Colorado
oh my role zombie yeah and and Denver
Aurora what I'm talking about don't
worry about it but we're talking we're
not gonna be 10 in the snow which is a
big thing we're gonna be cabining it Oh
toe bursts but don't you I feel like
you're like a greatly cold but I feel
yeah well you're a big old tough rough
rough guy I'm the guy that cold cuts
through them all whether you do right
yeah you do well in the cold no problem
yeah your book I was born yeah your beer
built for power you you you're gonna
have no problem you're gonna hop you're
gonna hoof the meat out of there buddy
but it would be an adventure and I've
had some of the best times with Joe
Rogan in my life on those on the three
trips I've done with Rinella I feel like
we you talked Rogan into doing it wasn't
me - he's always looking to kill you -
what do you think yeah yeah I'd be done
here's the kid yeah we could do that for
sure here's my thing though I okay I'm
not very good at gonna look any more
like a regular dude in every aspect of
the work and I don't know how many and
your hair is better there anyways but
you know I'm not very I'm not very I
don't know my way around the animal and
what kind of guns are we using or are we
using arrows that's my language you're
you're you don't know how to use I grew
up shooting heroes bro
no you you don't so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna use probably like a 30.6
I don't know what we used to shoot maybe
a wind max 100 probably something I used
as a dangerous out there for us same
thing I used to drop deer look at how
thick Rogan is he looks like a troll and
then there's like a little look at him
just he's sunk into the ground how long
ago is
like like not that long ago there's Ryan
Callahan one of the best people on the
planet hey baby
[Music]
I'm a little worried it'd be how many
days then also is there anything out
there they can hurt us
man I'm I mean I need some sort of
aspect of danger otherwise now mine wolf
and grizzly wolves not worried about
grizzly creationist yeah not lying not
where's Steve Steve's been charged by a
grizzly and a polar bear and a polar
bear came at him but that's a Trubel and
they had to shoot in the air polar bear
backed off shook his head came back shot
in the air again made a lot of noise
those are mama bear they tell me it was
just a regular old beer now though
grizzly was a mama bear tell it right
yeah they didn't kill it but they
spooked it now Steve also got the [ __ ]
ripped out of his butt by a moose moose
horn oh yeah well [ __ ] with moo moo so
ripped his jeans in half and I think got
him right in the ass Shan you ever been
hunting no just you just hunt fish I
just fish would you like to go hunting
yes you would I would die to use a gun
of course cat dude she's probably the
best shot of of us all you know what I
wish in forever
you know what no racists here but not a
lot even hunters out there not a lot of
Asian drit NASCAR drivers not my Asian
hunters probably yeah your pants you
start well yeah people in the Nam
sometimes they're people who live in
trees people who live on my boat houses
like you kind of have to for what are
you doing old school yeah the last time
I visited Vietnam
I saw a man on a boat with a bowl of
rice chopstick straight up uses
chopsticks grabbed a grasshopper from a
tree and ate it what is rice
Pam farm-to-table yep like that so you
save it nam which is interesting
oh that something no but not for me to
say so white way they bounce it
well yeah but Nam Vietnam you speak you
speak Vietnamese Wow how do you say yes
in
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and you
say no no come come come come what come
one more time how how they sing call me
calm
how come how come come I didn't solve
this whole calm cloud thing hey Hong
Kong asked me if I want to kiss you
no I want to answer mm-hmm say it like
you're playing your weird sexual fast
and say Brad do you want to kiss me
Brian do you want to suck Chin's rump
Tom do you say come I said count nope
you don't speak Vietnamese nope it's
Fitness nope what was it vet nummy
Vietnam vet nummies it's Vietnamese
Vietnamese [ __ ] like vitamins get your
vitamins yeah uh you want to go hunting
you want to go to Bordeaux what do you
want to do go I don't even know anymore
man yeah you know you're afraid I have a
hiatus I'm not shooting schooled like I
think I'd give you those dates no later
yeah no in the Goldbergs I probably want
me to come on the set though I get no
breaks this guy this guy gets no breaks
and so it's old you'll start shooting
later than with that you start shooting
later
well I start shooting I think October
1st bro I think said you be on hiatus I
have a break so I shoot three weeks on
one week off right but I won't week off
knowing the Goldbergs up I want a little
Coach Mellor
oh we got though yeah yeah I don't know
bro stacked I'm trying to get to Six
Flags
I want to go noodling though noodling
makes me excited you don't want to go
kill an alkyl I think I would with the
right circumstance how many days is it
though like three four but they listen
you got a flying of Colorado you'll find
a dia right then you got a drive it's
how far yeah but you're not laughing 12
99 bottles of beer on the wall 99
bottles of beer and one of the bottles
are gonna be one of those [ __ ] my
[ __ ] about thinking every day why are
you not wearing pants we have to get
ready for the hunt
you know what I'm saying yeah only go
noodling bro no we can't stop at
McDonald's for the tenth time no we
can't stop McDonald's yes he wants
another
apple pie that's the way he is when we
hunt ooh I do love apple pie how you do
the one thing that gets you going it's
been a nice there dude yeah I love pie
oh did you see that boy he's so worried
oh yeah that was back when I could eat
gluten before my skin issues no gluten
now we were talking before he came in
with cat I didn't know cat was also a
superhero expert like myself and yes and
we were talking about Tobey Maguire
trains at my gym I see him all the time
and I asked chin and cat I said who's
your spider-man cos cook Tobey Maguire's
my spider-man if Tobey Maguire is not
your spider-man [ __ ] you is not nobody
who's gonna be a spider-man that's the
original spider-man bro dance out
Washington right you would think he'd be
a great spider-man old spider-man I won
all black you know uh Donald Glover
childish gambino was gonna be spider-man
oh yeah oh yeah because he was black
yeah yeah because he's black yeah they
were like oh I actually have a t-shirt
that says the amazing game you know with
him as spider-man [ __ ] what size is it
huh what size is that sure small all
right I mean all right look
please find that shirt chin so I can buy
it what were you gonna say to your
you're a super superhero you know the
guy who plays spy the guy who plays
Superman that dimepiece oh yeah henry
cavill yes apparently he's uh apparently
he's you don't get better not doing it
anymore right
henry cavill out a super and amid Warner
Brothers DC you nourish a cup oh no did
he this my thing did he just not want to
get typecast at a super band like was he
sick of everyone be like Superman ah I
wonder hold on and like a lot of actors
like the real actors think it's a
cop-out when you play like a superhero
they like make fun of it it's a lot of
money it's a lot of money and when I say
people make fun of it they're also broke
actors who wish they were Spider Man and
super axe actually cuz think about it
think about who somebody played [ __ ]
Batman the greatest actor adverts I'm
saying Christian Bale correct exactly
and also I was also leaning towards Ben
Affleck to a huge fan of okay
my
Keating the val kilmer any other
brain-busters Jack Nicholson okay mmm
rest in peace [ __ ] home boy who died
Heath Ledger Joker yeah
then the dimepiece of all timepieces
Jared Leto yeah okay some real quality
oh no doubt yeah they let you play like
the like like any villain in a comic
book here that's how does so nice
cashiers a Riddler I'd really love to
have well there's well okay I'm The
Riddler nope nope it was fun I've got a
question for all of you if you don't get
the answer you'll die die die die die no
here's the dude I'm not saying beat you
the Riddler from Adam West's Batman I
need you current Riddler
you'd be a psychopath like bipolar
there's like gay I uh
who said I'm gay you're calming a
somebody kill him oh never mind I have a
gun gang gang prefers weird strange
it's weird no it's cashews the relearn
anything though how about it everybody
come on fans mount a whole campaign for
me to be the red fur well - you've
ruined it I mean you can beat me enough
- was that a snake oh no it fell from
the ceiling I'm bitching the day is only
gonna die slowly let's take my what is
it no panic though okay that's a good
[ __ ] come on come on fighter and kir
army get behind me I've never seen the
Superman's I haven't really yeah I
haven't gotten around to watch I heard
they were all bad so that's why was it
he dating Gina Carano
do you know I'm not sure they were
dating for a little bit I remember
recently there was thing where Demi
Lovato tried to do a whole thirst trap
to get to him
BJJ and I guess you were like posting up
video like right issues I do yeah I just
for me Henry Cavill isn't he doesn't do
it for me
it's an actor no I mean as an actor he
is an actor I'm not that him I don't
really yeah he
says he bidden I don't think he's that
he was in the man uncle no he was in
Iron Man heard that mr. Impossibles read
a Man From UNCLE he's in Mission
Possible Hertz read a queue really
Demi Lovato I'm a huge meal ooh
and her talents yes not her drug choice
she's hungry uh Kogi yes yes correct
and I feel like that her call the boxes
is that would be her Brian yep no we're
staring a different girl named Demi
Lovato I'm a fan
oh I'm a huge fan where are we going
with superheroes though you're huge
super yeah who's your spider-man when I
was younger Tobey Maguire but I don't
like to think I'm spider-man 3 we don't
talk about spying around 3 you don't
like spider-man 3
we're vent so convoluted here's the
problem with spider-man 3 the venom with
some [ __ ] that was some [ __ ] and
I'm supposed to be jacked and swole yeah
yeah when did we get we got an emo Peter
Parker we got a Peter Parker that looked
like Pete Wentz from Fall Out Boy that
was strange
when he's what bring up this clip chin
who was Peter Parker and in spider-man 3
Tobey Maguire but bring up bring up
spider-man 3 toe Maguire the dancing uh
daughter what would you call emo scene
yeah he's dancing he's like ha yeah he
doesn't work the way he used to yeah
there it is this is where I was like
dude I'm sold on so I ran three it's my
favorite part
he it's all cool this that big dick
energy what do you think a big dick
energy you should be thinking of this
exact scene in the movie he's all nerdy
right then he gets that big dick energy
give me a little volume for godsake Jen
really I say give me some Mel's it hi
Nick Nick you're on speakerphone bro
just FYI
Wayde Nikolas I'm you're on the podcast
as we speak
oh great I'm psyched yeah man you sound
really high man oh no you didn't feel
like a wagon did you seems like 20 bucks
for the 20 bucks
I don't think so it's supposed to be
free bro I don't know dude you sound
you don't sound yourself sharp
oh you don't sound sorry you're speaking
slow bro trip you're like all right
where are you bro oh [ __ ] Nick you're
supposed to be just let's roll Jen yeah
no [ __ ] go Nick was just telling me
how he plays soccer I play soccer and
then I get injured immediately and then
I stop one play like a men's league on
like Sundays like a bunch of dudes get
together and play just have some ladies
and it's and it's kind of fun it's super
fun it's not very competitive it's
lovely and then every time I like [ __ ]
up my ankle or you know is that after
you jump in the air and score with your
head if you need to holy let me know bro
there you go do you play goalie no but
I'd like them yeah I bet you could do it
if you got good reaction times you
should be fine
it's a big day he's a big kid it's a it
well it's not all the world I'll show ya
really I honestly it's all about you
know it's all about just seeing that see
in the field and anticipating so you've
got to have a panoramic eye you got to
be able to see the whole you know all of
it and and when you do then you react
yeah here being super general without
sports I played sports I know what
soccer is I know what this boy no no I
know isn't a thing I like have met you
know no I'm sure that I'm a cool dude
that I play soccer a sportsman I'm a
sportsman well I said to Nick in the
bathroom I go dude you know you're
you're thick I mean you have a you're
putting together well of course you
brilliant in the bath mine did Nick
Kroll up and asked him out athletic yeah
sure in the bathroom just a guy he's
like what it's all i matters didn't you
didn't you play goalie against a very
good an Olympic soccer player
I wanted to oh we wanted to shoot the
video with Hope Solo no may as well been
she could probably beat me up hope so
look good I think probably take you yeah
I agree
all of us yeah she's a big beautiful
woman yeah you guys see I was I was
listening to the show on the way over
and it's like I was like oh right okay
I'm gonna talk about [ __ ] UFC in here
man
and I'm like you thought you were I'm
ready to and I know nothing about how
many guys think that we talked about
fighting
yeah not true the opposite yes people
think is a sports show all the time
yeah yeah how would you guys classify
what you're doing here just a couple of
guys bro couple bros and sweet talk yeah
well offensive talk yeah do you talk
about where you are in where it where
this show where you taping the show
yes live esta it's like I walked out it
I don't come out to ply this often right
it's real Playa Vista out there it's
well yeah yeah yeah it's really
interesting it's that new development
vibe and there's like you know young
professional outdoor spaces of like
shared space and everybody's like got
their [ __ ] together and has a nice
backpack yeah you know what's
interesting about that and this is
what's Venice is becoming I always feel
like when I see people who have all
their [ __ ] together and their backpacks
so so in other words they're down the
earth yeah everything they have on is
very expensive yes and also there's a
lot of money it's quiet money yes exist
like their rent is easily sixty five
hundred bucks a month with this insane
apartment yeah and what happens I think
when there's that kind of youth and
ambition and money is that there's
actually no community all right it's
kind of like in their own bubble yes
right do you feel that way I never I I
don't know it's not everybody's very
antiseptic yeah well I think it's like
they're it's like nerd bros it's like I
guess I got to go get my [ __ ] done I'm
gonna start this company we're gonna get
a move in I'm programming I'm gonna
[ __ ] take it we're gonna open it up
and it's a startup I'm like oh we
recycle yeah but we recycle and I'm
gonna I'll [ __ ] you know yeah I'll
just do what I got to do this is yeah
yeah I'll do an outreach program but
they have to come to me yeah
that's a good deal though that's what I
feel like this is for me like you guys
are doing an outreach for me and now
you've done some that that Broadway show
which I missed I'm sorry I missed it
there you well I heard such good things
about it I was amazing it was I saw I
thought and what this is that shows you
how terrible parent I am my son's
obsessed from sausage party really with
the douche yeah man how old's your son
two and a half it's just like you don't
know what they're saying but his
favorite characters that that [ __ ]
douche man yeah that's a bummer it's a
bummer for or it's like you're like okay
this is my kid like I've been trying to
slowly under like get into kids minds
and and do like animated kids movie
stuff like that and just sort of turn
them into socialist and turn them in a
bunch of animated movies though right I
have done I've been able to do a few of
them it's fun it's fun to do and a lot
of work it's not bad I just came from
one that's where I came from to today
it's like the no it's weird it's like
every four months all the animations of
the interesting thing about it across
the board is and I'm not here to talk
about big mouth which comes out October
5th on Netflix my animated show big
mouth it's called big Netflix Netflix
October what October 5th oh and that's
called big ok and it's on Netflix and it
comes out October 5th October yeah and
that's on Netflix that's on Netflix yeah
but this but the animation process is
such a crazy one because you just keep
you have different there's so many
stages to getting an animated show done
with like you know a radio play a new
animatic screening and do like a color
screening and there's so many stages to
it that it's sort of very laborious you
keep having to go back to it but you
also keep getting a constant like making
it better you just keep getting more and
more shots I mean like oh that jokes not
working that like it's like in sausage
party I was always the douche but the
original version of the douche was like
like I clearly wanted like Patrick
Stewart to do it you know like a Disney
villain kind of guy yeah and I did it at
the table read and they eventually were
like [ __ ] it we'll just have him do it
so I was playing it as like a English
like Jafar one of the III figure you
played as like - like version like like
an Escalade version of like your Jersey
Shore right so what is the character I
don't know the original characters like
yeah you can pull will find the well why
don't we play the the under - the
version of it yeah
YouTube's great by the way if people
haven't checked it out people need to go
check out all YouTube videos on there
and there's music podcasts anything you
want really it's a great place so I just
again you guys are not sponsored by them
this is a unsolicited sure are so check
out the website YouTube get on the app
YouTube it's a great it's a great it's a
great app it's a great essent of this
voice deep so they grow star they're all
characters and they like condom if you
have never seen some super hell it's
embarrassing I will tell you very much
that you look [ __ ] disgusting bro you
know what people say like oh your gosh
are you from New York I reach my grove
in the tri-state area the suburbs yes
but they're playing those guys so I
started doing that guy I started doing a
character Bobby bottleservice letter now
it's like oh Jesus I'm probably almost
10 ish years ago and then literally I
was like oh I got a I got a break on
this guy that it's like I used to do
talking to girls like that guys like
excuse me can I talk to you for
something you know like that guy
girls girls liked him that I could play
the guy that bothered them yes so I was
like foetida and then I was in Vegas I
know what it was we were canvassing for
Obama shout-out to a Barack Obama by the
way former president United said no he
was
he does listen the pockets but not a lot
right alright well so that if he catches
this one great if not you know no me
okay shut up to Brock not to Trump no
shout out to Donald Bobby but we were
canvassing for Obama we were in Vegas we
went to a club and I was like ooh
bottleservice be funny and do like a you
know bottle service bah bah bah bah bah
that's that becomes the guy then Jersey
Shore comes out like six months later
cuz I had been watching all that like
true life I live on the shore true live
sad all that [ __ ] which were great sort
of like feeders for that guy and then
and then Jersey Shore came out and I was
like oh good you know everybody anyway
so then years later I'm doing this the
vo for this movie as the douche but I'm
doing like an English villain I'm like
how dare you know like that kind of
Disney thing and because there's so many
stages to animation my last session when
I'm just doing like cleanup of like
whatever they're like so we tested the
movie out there your guy is like a
Disney villain not like a Pixar villain
we're doing a Pixar ish kind of thing
and it's you know that's a note they can
make or break you in that moment yeah
yeah and they were like so in the last
session I changed that we did the whole
movie in one run and I just redid it
then oh wow
and that was such a good night it was so
smart it was like doosh like be the
modern douche bag got some like [ __ ]
you know school yeah not like Jafar yeah
who's the douche bag is I don't when
shoutout to Jafar shout out the whole
Latin team
okay especially the guys it didn't make
it in the credit your [ __ ] shout out
to met Alan Menken shout out yeah
no no then they again all of them listen
all these guys are listening to the pod
oh my god how long so how long did it
take so obviously the movies so it
normally for cousin a motion picture
takes longer than like does we have we
have a lot we you have less time in a
series but you still get it in the TV
stuff it's like when you go sure to show
you now like normally you're like hope
we got the script right hope we got it
on the day hope we can save it in the
Edit you got sort of three kind of times
to check in on [ __ ] right with the
animation there's just there's like four
more four or five more steps built into
it so you're like oh we didn't get that
performance we'll bring that back in or
we change this storyline which we can
totally do in ways that you could in it
when you're shooting live-action so it
requires a little more like fine-tuning
throughout but you just get more shots
at it so you get that in TV and in film
but film you do like I don't know I
don't know how many sessions they get do
you like doing do you find do you have a
love hate relationship with acting or do
you oh yeah I mean I like it but like
I'll say this go into an animated movie
got only got to do it every once in a
while for like four hour chunks this in
the middle of the day or show it's a
reasonable day when we were writing the
show it's like it's a reasonable day
yeah when you're shooting when you're in
production it [ __ ] it takes some
weird talling you because you haven't
there's so little clarity about like
what your day is what your week looks
like what the even just the peace of
mind to know that you're like I will be
able to accomplish this task
you don't even you're just like I don't
know well what about when doing John
Mulaney with that the the Broadway thing
oh hello that was great the best part
one of the great things about that was
you were like okay every day I'm going
to my theater in Midtown I was living in
like around Washington Square I was like
I can walk up there every day around
five or six worked for like three four
hours and be done with the day and be
like you guys wrote this right yeah yeah
yes because because it's important to
note for people getting a show financed
our way on Broadway
look hard yeah man oh hello I'm Broadway
man you guys are best buds
yeah we've been weaving we went to
college together we did improv together
at in college I cast him in the improv
group
and I met him Jesus I don't know that's
like almost I don't know seven seventeen
year whatever it is I start doing
stand-up together same time yeah he was
still in school for a few years he lived
he lived with me in my on my couch one
summer and was like we would go to open
mikes and it was like the you know he's
great yeah he's the [ __ ] funniest so
we just with them we and we started
doing these characters like I don't know
10 12 years ago we hosted did you ever
go to Rififi when it was when you were
in New York Jim Rififi know who put that
on that was like I got a fez yeah
exactly we've seen that same crew of
like it was the alts
when there was more of a differe
differentiation I did it back when I was
you were younger I did it back when I
was rebar yeah example ER and all right
over Lou no did you do Luna la una Lau
yeah see I remember going to Luna and
then like Luna source built enough so
that there could be another like kind of
like nightly what now everything is all
more mixed up now in a very New York not
how old are you Nick forty in New York
we had these we had these awesome sort
of like alternative comedy spaces
certainly so yeah so I get my bar yeah
then and so you'd it in Fez and
different lights like basically really
literally underground that's cool so all
the young up-and-coming comics we'd all
get a chance first time I like when Zac
Alf and I would dress like a scribe
hundred there wouldn't be like open mics
or zero was there were very stages but
what happened was it was it's not that
similar from like LA it like on cabaret
or Largo or it was that vibe in New York
can we just right so like all so like
because so we did stand-up we were doing
open mics with you know and my little I
was with like chelsea peretti and and
these other folks who were like well
we're old are you at this time we start
standing up like oh oh - oh - my I
started yeah Oh - I started I did my
first open mic like that was my new
year's resolution and and was doing like
improv UCB training
simultaneously and then that it all sort
of coalesced where
Olsson there was UCB to do like stand-up
her character bits but you could also go
to like Rififi where it was like me and
mmm that me and John hosted a show and
it was sort of like but we hosted it as
those characters you know these upper
Westside divorcees were like you know
obsessed with Alan Alda and you know
that looks you both look so terrible
somewhat fun or my it's the most dude
it's the most fun in the world I mean
it's like Fisher boys you guys are
[ __ ] around for years yeah man in
pain yes so cool we had people come to
watch it dude who's the hottest show in
town yeah it was crazy we we did it and
then we so we did an off-broadway at
this place the Cherry Lane Theatre yeah
for like a month like one-man show like
we were sharing it with Colin Quinn he
had the show during the day and then we
sort of like morphed it into herb you
know stuff like that and and then we
went and toured it a bit and then we
brought it to Broadway and then we shot
it and it was the most fun that was
probably I would say that might have
might be the most fun thing ever which
is you're on Broadway every night you're
doing your show it's with your buddy
you wrote it so we could [ __ ] around and
change anything we wanted night tonight
be a different guest that we would
interview every night oh really oh yeah
we would prank someone with too much
tuna which is their bit they present a
huge tuna sandwich
so that's too much tuna but it really
it's a chance to do an interview so we
interviewed I mean we did a hundred and
38 shows but we interviewed got to [ __ ]
with everyone 30 was it bittersweet when
it ended yeah it was it was because we
you know I don't know about you guys are
you do a gig you're like all right like
we were gonna go do this thing and we're
like we want to do like four months
because I don't want to be I don't want
to kill myself on Broadway for a year
whatever it was and then and then you're
like exhausted it's very hard and then
it gets fun and for us I was like by the
end I was like they they got a new show
coming in here we could we didn't give
him enough notice to be like I want to
keep doing this because I by the end I
was like I can keep doing this it's just
like I'm with
with John I'm with his wife and who does
our makeup the three of us just chilling
every night I'd walk up there do a show
for New York have someone crazy could be
interviewed
like I mean weak are one of our last in
reserves Letterman we got Letterman and
then that way I was like this is bananas
you know we got but we got to everyone
both Hines may be in the audience Oh
like Seinfeld would be watching the show
and then in the middle of the show we'd
pull him up on stage and interview him
for like a half-hour live oh my god yes
and it was the [ __ ] best most fun and
so be like but it could be Seinfeld or
Letterman or Tina Fey everybody comes
through or it's like f murray Abraham or
Paul Sorvino or [ __ ] Robin bird you
know I mean like just any bizarre as in
the porn Robin Burton cable-access he
was known you'd know her but in New York
option she was the cable access before
the internet channel J show where she
would it was really well I would watch
that [ __ ] religiously yeah this is such
a high bird which was younger she was
hot of [ __ ] and it's just like it's
crazy early New York porn star stripper
she's like she's the she was younger she
was yeah yeah he's just like crazed
hilarious but she was doing she and she
and Epstein whoever that dude from Rose
grew oh he's incredible how gold seen a
big hear him breathing so but they bring
alkyl al goldstein and Robin bird
brought Cablevision or whatever the
cable company was to the Supreme Court
and won yes about like right you know
free speech alcohol sober with the
raccoon because she got bit by a raccoon
at her house and yeah it's so I'm like
an hour shows a lot of raccoon [ __ ] and
it was very anyway so you have like high
you have every version of it and we
finish the show and we'd go to like a
few of those places in that area there's
like
my favorite is trying Joe Allen's it's
right there great Jones it's like up in
the dark my time wooden bar piano bar
piano bar the the walls are covered with
posters for fail only failed Broadway
shows [ __ ] die take em bro I'll [ __ ]
tell you I will walk out of your show
brains man you wouldn't because our show
has no intermission yeah but we just
like but that's the thing is that was
the most fun as we're like I've been to
a hundred Broadway shows I love we love
theater and also their [ __ ] that drives
you nuts and theater here's everything
that drives you nuts about being an
audience member in theater and that was
the most fun it's to be like what are we
pretending like we're not in the [ __ ]
same room yeah you don't I mean you
watch it play even a play you see you
guys are might you like plays like I
like plays but I get like plays like
it's like us embarrassing like they're
like in some English [ __ ] town in the
1930s it's like embarrassing I don't
believe this if you smell gonna fight
the English you're looking at us but
you're looking at a window you're not
cold
you're covering yourself Barry stop last
stop screaming for your dog Sheba no
[ __ ] dog out here so I depends on the
play but I would say I had the choice or
not you said you almost went to spring
so you know I went to I saw
Springsteen's again it is I was not a
Springsteen fan he's not my guy at all
yeah you go either Billy Joel you go
Springsteen I think you fall in one camp
or another yeah I'm an American man yes
Springs yeah it's but if you're a
[ __ ] Jew from New York hey Joe
yeah if you're [ __ ] socialists you
loves to crash cars drop can rush up
yeah I would love to the Russians and
the pogroms have the 1805 gentleman does
your boy John does he still ride on
Saturday Night Live or now no that was
over for a while yeah he hosted this
past year I know it was great - yeah I
mean so he'll if you know yeah I don't
think he's ready but he's one of the few
few comics that shouldn't say whew
there's a bunch what make me feel like
this but when I watch the special I
think he's one of the one of the best
there is right now i watch the special
I'm like dude he's so much smarter than
everyone in the room yeah man more than
everybody it's the way that's the weird
thing about him is he is smart and
everyone in the room but he has that
ability to speak in a way that everybody
can understand so it's never made martyr
than the room yes it's just smart yeah
yeah I saw him for the first time a year
ago oh yeah and I and I had heard but
I'd you know I don't watch and I watched
this guy this young man get up there and
destroy I've been doing stand-up for way
too long to be impressed yeah and and
but I watched him and sometimes I'll
watch a guy and I go well you're as good
as it gets delivers his cadence old I
just walked up to I didn't know him I go
dude you're so hot yeah was he like -
back then like in college he's like I
met him afresh I was a senior he was a
freshman and it was like I was the
director of my group and I was like big
I was like I'm the [ __ ] director of
my college and private group they're
pretty [ __ ] good right now yeah the
track asked him and and within a month I
was like oh [ __ ] man I'm not funny like
that you know it was like that when you
knew right away Taran Killam yes Taran
Killam 19 years old makes his way on
MADtv 19 he was on MADtv 19 years old
that dude and yes yeah you got it when I
met him we were doing how I Met Your
Mother
shout out to all you guys shout out at
the seagull shot
to the network itself shoutout to Ames
CBS shoutout to 20 Century Fox's studio
there thank you shout to everybody but
but he he was he had I think we're doing
see where he had a P and the like he the
breathing and everything he was doing
was I was just like you're such a good
actor yeah how the [ __ ] you this could
yeah I feel like this sometimes there's
comics of both you guys to but when I
watched John stuff and Neil Brandon I'm
like oh I think it's like a younger kid
watching like a LeBron James like I
can't [ __ ] jump that high you will
you will jump that high thanks dude give
it about 10 years I thought ah we
[ __ ] burned him I know we just find a
burn on man well he's not that old
though I'm 53 head working on the first
I've had my jet to plastic surgery
shoutout shuttle doctor shoutout to the
doctors who make make these people
beautiful people's live shoutout to the
plastic surgery doctor specifically who
are helping people who have body
dysmorphia from taking selfies to have
their do you know that people are
getting plastic surgery now done that is
to gauge themselves know that they look
better in selfies what i swear to god
this world look it up would you put
would you put shoutout to google by the
way for being one of the greatest search
engines in the game rush out out the
challenge in for being terrible on
google's buddies from korea to shout out
to the korean people of north korea but
I will not shut out thank you John
Thank You Chad to his sister who went to
the Olympics in his steed that's right
yeah yeah yeah yeah I went to the I was
there I shot a tiny little weird movie
inside of the Olympia really yeah
is it out no it's not out soccer in the
Olympics rider man for okay I said true
because that feels like I didn't keep me
hanging about damn it's totally
different vibe not liberal not really
you're playing this way for how do you
feel about the sugar and the carrot
juice are you okay with that you know
I'm not just a lot of sugar in the
carrot juice but I love it really yeah I
love carrot juice here's a little sugar
in it how much how much you guys worried
about sugar nursery do I look like a
sugar bomb I'll take my shirt off right
yeah I have psoriasis but I got a great
part right juicer Isis from the lack of
sugar or from oh that's a good point
maybe increase your sugar intake [ __ ]
and you got sir I have an eczema I've
got a constant eczema but you got a
psoriasis right yeah but my diets
solving a lot of problems I think yeah I
don't need apparently I don't need sugar
dairy or gluten now right but I still
drink wine tonight and I fall off the
wagon here and there yeah you have any
health problems near 40 I'm 40 I Eve I
eat like three to four loaves of bread a
day and I find that have you ever tried
to substitute the white bread yeah I
mean I did like you know ballpark
Frank's just said yeah I don't know mark
Franks by the way I will straight up be
like now I'm making it I want ballpark
shout-out to ballpark shadow no I'm
sorry that the shout-out to the ballpark
Frank bun yeah I don't like the Wiener
no you do yes
so I'm with my mother this weekend in
Utah I'm here with my mother
Oh Jim golfing shout-out to moms and my
mom mm-hmm we're golfing guy guys the
guy who's with my mother said I want a
frankfurter hot dog the guy says she's
from New York the guy says all right I
go yeah but they got fillers and the guy
goes now it's grass-fed beef and my
mother goes you're getting a hot dog I
go I don't know if it's good for my skin
she goes oh shut up
yeah oh my god and mustard and I ate
that [ __ ] hot list and it was the
best thing I've ever had in my life and
I'm and I'm probably better for it yeah
I think if you eat a good clean hot dog
as a health that's a hell I said lips
and [ __ ] yeah your body doesn't know
the difference
just eat it yeah stop peeing would you
put on it um but they have a mustard
situation
sauerkraut great great and I in a bun
great no ketchup no no really
ketchup my dad one of those I like
grilled onions my dad was super I
remember as it's young like he was like
walked into a deli what you like I was
probably seven in the car and he's like
you want a hot dog as they yeah he's
like what do you want I was like mustard
and ketchup and he's like or I just said
ketchup and he was like he looked at me
disappointed yes it was like I know it's
like in New York that you don't put
ketchup on a hot dog but I think that's
like my mother grew up corn a cat's
telling yeah so that that was the place
yeah and there's no ketchup there either
yeah cuz I feel like ketchup overwhelms
it yes I think weakness to ketchup I
want that set I want I want and I want
and I want yellow mustard you know one
[ __ ] deli must you don't like the
spicy mustard I'll take a spicy mustard
I just know what that French is yellow
that I can just [ __ ] you like
highlighter yellow yeah it's from he's
from Aurora though not on the same I
like that [ __ ] yeah that's what I like
my own yeah yeah yeah yeah we say he's
but you're from Aurora you're from Saudi
Arabia dude you don't hear you don't get
a vote
dude you're not American bro you went to
the dermatologist you have a spine your
head let me get so much weight you guys
know Bryan is not unlike right now
what's happening she stood up you know
sorry Nick no like the same kind of
frame yeah man I don't know about those
Saudi Arabian hotdogs on there better be
no pork in them there's not
dude chatter Saudi Arabia a dishonor
maybe the nation of set out to the the
royalty the shout out to the oil
companies shoutout to a cow shot out to
the yeah about to go so much darker yeah
I almost did to him here's a girl in New
York ran out of juice on my little
Easter shut up okay Jews there's a girl
I should have told you there's a girl
who is nothing short of beautiful she's
on the cover of tattoo magazine or was
and she was beautiful beautiful matter a
long long time ago and we simpie about a
year ago and she I got a random at and
talked to her in a long time I got a
random text and she said do you know
Nick Kroll I'm obsessed with him oh and
I think I text back he's gay
this is a year ago good yeah nothing
with it and did not have a girl um I'm
I'm a tattoo artist I didn't think
that's what she was actually interested
no that wasn't about it wasn't about
she's obsessed with the tattoo work I
knew yes your art my art was weird is
that she's just did some Saint dimepiece
who dates you know she dates like
rockers and she dates like you no other
tattoo guys you the funny guy bro she
wants that she wanted Nick Kroll sure
since she was obsessed with you
I haven't to come in a contractor thank
you and she's on the cover of tattoo
magazine yes
is that a real man I don't like a fake
magazine that baby feels like you know
like a prop like you're like you're in a
scene comedy like yeah you're like
enough you're you're threatening him in
a barbershop Seagal in a barbershop and
you're reading tattoo magazine Jason
seemed too talented bro
yeah he's a big boy I saw that movie end
of tour which I had not seen of him in
Jesse Eisenberg where it's a good movie
it's good it's good it's good it's like
making a movie so [ __ ] hard even when
a movies good I watch them I was like
it's a good movie everyone's doing
everyone's doing exactly what they're
doing and well I don't but also like I
don't know man I know know I ever hear
back think about how it shot stuff to do
it's hard to was letting you guys away
that's a good question let me think
about that last movie that blew me away
movie I really enjoyed was the jungle
book for whatever reason really going
get out psych for Lion King man bro for
the next you know this guy's team
Favreau your team Favreau beginning I
don't know if I am too but shout out to
Joe you know Vince what's the the movie
that won all the awards shape of water
shape of water that blew me away I hated
this movie I loved it bro
shout out to Gary Moeller Toro that all
shout to the fishermen shout out to the
hand with a
from Pan's Labyrinth yes that's a good
movie I really liked was Wind River
what's that like a western one no award
based off a true general really real in
River yeah they did the trailer will
catch suck you I didn't really I think
the trailers that's why I didn't want to
see it oh it's such a long story short
he's a he's a hunter and he's a girl it
ends up dead Elizabeth Olsen is with her
she's a she's really good she's good
yeah and he finds he finds the killers
but it's a really wild did you see that
movie three billboards yeah I didn't see
it would you think rockwell is amazing
and it great performances III liked I
don't know III had it's so weird it's
like you want like there's a surreal
that's like you don't like any movie
yeah well so you know like anything I
mean it's well that thing is just like
it's so much harder to make a movie like
look I was talking to the dude who made
end of the [ __ ] world that there's a
show on Netflix it's about these two
like T's not big mouth on Netflix it
comes I think it's October shot the big
mouth shot to navigate out to shout out
to Netflix shout out to Ted Serena's the
head of Netflix shout out to a der
Goldberg the co-creator give yourself a
shout out shout out to Nick Kroll
co-creator big mouth good October first
shout out to release dates shout out to
the day of October 15 yeah yeah - shout
out to your brother Dave crawl dear oh I
wish I burn them
he burned me by saying that I was breath
my Brotherhood with Steve Burns yeah all
of them all the Steve Burns out there
not just the Steve burn we know I love
Steve go on so you said the end of the
world Netflix oh right so it's a guy
who's gonna make a movie of it and it's
the show about this like these two kids
like teens who like get loose like in
England they're [ __ ] both them are
different weirdo like it's sort of like
a Natural Born Killers thing where they
then go off on the road and are like
crazy together as a movie as a show it's
[ __ ] terrific cuz you can watch it's
kind of like we're talking about with
like Hamilton me like the intermission
and it's [ __ ] long you don't wanna do
anything
for three hours in a row that you can
watch a show that was a movie you watch
a two or three episodes and if you want
to stay for if you want to binge through
and watch like two and a half hours of
content like a movie you can do it you
know if not you can break it up over
like two or three days or a week or
whatever and you're good it's just
harder to keep people focused for a mmm
for two hours on a movie yes or play you
don't see a lot of movies that are over
two hours these days and that's like a
war movie or super boring yeah I don't
you know and there's a reason for it
shout out to time shut up shut up to
Millennials but not have enough
attention span shout out the Millennials
when I on the Tishman shout out to the
concept of time and how elastic or
construct other time father
speaking of physics yeah yeah what was
so what movie blew you away oh [ __ ] man
I gotta think oh I see a bunch of
documentaries recently documented three
identical strangers have you seen that
one to talk to doc no what it's it was
out exciters it was out of theaters but
I'm shooting it I don't know what it's
gonna be on thought sense three
identical strangers it's about these
three twins they're its triplets that
were separated I don't want to give it
away a lot basically it's you realize
that these kid these boys are like 17
years old yeah get find out like like
one of them shows up at a college and
everyone's like hey man hey man like
they already know him it's his first day
he's like I don't know what you're
[ __ ] talking about and they're like
this guy's like dude someone was my
roommate who just left this school who
looks exactly like you and so he's like
let's go meet him and he meets him and
it's like you're my [ __ ] twin brother
they didn't know each other that gets on
the news and then there's a third dude
who's like meat and so they all then
[ __ ] brothers at like 18 years old in
like nineteen damnit school and like go
on every show have some part what's it
on chin that's what's nuts on that and
it's great it's great it's great story
it's a great story you've seen all the
I'm sure you've seen all the regular
Doc's the big dogs yeah I saw everything
that dog you mentor in some it's about
dog the best documentary about Dog the
Bounty Hunter watch the [ __ ] up that's
the only dude I've ever asked whether if
you know okay I just says Carol Burnett
for a picture and then I asked the other
celebrity press to think of big Jimmy
was dog the back of it yeah it was like
cher brought the sheen you got it man
sure really yeah he's not the wine I've
seen they use the n-word about 50 times
and and then to his son and then for
dating a black woman and then his show
he came back on a show yeah that was
fine yeah he started about her what
happened was he doing now
hunting criminals thing for [ __ ] TV
deals great hair thing to pay the bill I
don't know how many TV deals that man's
yeah I doubt the dog the bounty hunter
shout out to his wife Beth was fatties
yeah yes here I think weirdly shout out
to his wife Beth who I think follows me
on Twitter every now and again I'll get
like a a like from from Doug about a on
his wife brie on Twitter so shout out to
her dude you made it man if she's made
you've made it have you had a have you
had a big celebrity come home and say
hey I'm a fan
no it's such a bummer man [ __ ]
Dog the Bounty Hunter let's see oh
shout out to mr. Rogers see that boring
hood yeah did you dig it I thought was a
little slow for my like it's I mean it's
he's it's slow it kind of makes you cry
made me cry didn't raise on planes me
too I watch it on the plane you know
they say you're more more emotional than
that cuz you're up in the air instead
yeah yeah oh I feel it they say you're
way more emotional on plane yeah I could
I watched mr. Rogers I got through like
30 minutes
like damn I hope this picks up yeah I
don't know I don't want to start in the
theatres we were how Wendy kids he is as
a grown man dress is that the whole
thing is like he wasn't that guy but I
think people wanted to put that on him
but he wasn't I from what I can tell and
shout out to mr. Roger shout out his
whole family knew him in and produced
the show how it shout out to the whole
team the whole crew behind that miss
shout out to the puppets on his set
shout out to but it's yeah the other
dark mark I saw another one more we can
say about mr. Rogers though oh that I he
molested me yeah you can look us in the
eye he had to cover spaceman yeah come
sit on my lap and tell me about my
cardigan no shout out to no shout out to
[ __ ] Sandusky no no no shout out to
the [ __ ] priest no shout out to the
USC doctor no shout out to the [ __ ]
USC doctor no no shout out to Larry
Nasser no shadow show shot up to that
unless he gets out and starts a movie
studio yeah okay so here's what I want
to know guys this pillow
yeah that's does that look like you and
me in that Nick a little bit a little
bit a little Bobby B this is like it
falls in that space you know what Paulie
talks a little bit like the character
you really a little bit yeah he's from
Rome he's from Brooklyn yeah you know
what I've actually I actually think
people have sent me a picture of him
being like that looks like a character
you do yeah that would make sense yeah
hilarious he's got that shape yeah that
that shaped it's got amazing kinase a
voice too you know yeah I bet he's
[ __ ] funny
yeah he's hilarious oh and you're in
love with him or their hearts going on
yeah I'm not sure with all those good
the same you're a bro love because I
work together on this thing we really
hit it all right black good chemistry
there that's all you can ask for Brendan
looks very african-american in that yeah
yeah yeah oh dude it's and then who are
these in the background
that'd be Floyd Mayweather and karma
Gregg in the background that's what we
worked for on Showtime together and then
those are my Christian
yes boots I got clogs so that's a big
gig was that a scary giggle because
everyone was watching that one right
everyone's watching that one everyone
wanted that gig there's a lot of process
to get it yeah not really I don't know I
didn't think about it I don't get to
heart and so when someone sent me like a
throwback Thursday picture and who's
happening like I think around this time
last year maybe a few weeks ago and I'm
like [ __ ] that's right that was a big
deal man
yeah it was cool but what you're going
through you know I don't I'm Floyd and
shout out to Showtime shout out to
Floyd's baby mamas being in the crowd at
everything we did yeah shut up what I
mean she was they were shout out to all
the girls that he's dating Yeah right
yes you have a few different ones
there's not monster it's a roster shout
out to the wads of cash she carries
around yeah shout out to the diamond
necklaces he wears yeah and shout out to
McGregor and his kid I want here's what
I want to see his kid is it doesn't have
a kid yeah a little [ __ ] kid a little
kid I want to see him and DJ Khaled's
kids fight oh that's a good one I would
like to see that I would like to see
that I would definitely like to see that
if you guys are getting on a plane yeah
do you put them on the Logan Paul ksi
YouTube fight yeah man the kiddos fight
on the nikana D do how was that fight
did that happen already though I'd have
fun yeah and then they're doing another
one here now lady pretty rugged guy yeah
he's a big strong oh if I call him
rugged is it like if you give me a
hundred words I would call welcome home
kid the youtuber he's not athletic er
he's big strong yeah but rug is not a
word you'd go with what didn't he fight
for six rounds
took some shots he got tired toward the
house you look pretty good man and he
did that a pay-per-view yeah they sold
it on their platform they make up how
much they made some [ __ ] money on you
know what they sold a lot there were
only ten dollars but he's come out and
said because there's so much of an
overhead because they don't have
promoters right right they have to pay
for the venue yeah yeah take it so the
trade all this stuff he was basically
breaking even but it's good publicity
right
they broke even on that they did I
thought he made like ten million dollars
I'm crazy yeah shout-out to making big
chucks a changed man
shut everyone even you know what I mean
can you get some current events dude
yeah actually that three identical
stranger yeah yeah so it says it's not
streaming yet [ __ ] guys I'm sorry about
that
what did you see bro I saw in the movie
theater and so I want to apologize to
you guys for presenting apology humble
wherewithal to say he's wrong I was
wrong when I said that the movie existed
that is not even available on Netflix
yet I want to apologize to you I want
apologize to your fans man I want to
apologize to Beth the Bounty Hunter the
first one is an old lady who's a fantasy
romance novelist who actually wrote once
about how to kill your husband and get
away with it yeah she's charged with
murdering her husband yeah Wow
of course man yeah I take one look at I
like she's a murderer you do it one way
or the other you do it you do it how
maggin you do it how Nancy Crampton
brophy did it you do a pre a pre
admittance or you go OJ's you got how
can go either I did it yeah if I did it
here's how I would've done and she's
like it when I do it busy day for me
bringing it how to marry your husband
wow this is crazy
how did she kill him chin he was shot so
but they don't know it's her for a fact
she's charged with it right well it's an
interesting alibi where she could be
like my fans are [ __ ] knowing that
they like it's so easy for someone to
you know or this you know like of course
I'm the suspect or in the book on it
yeah why would I be so stupid as to
appoint someone after I've talked about
killing it that's so crazy
okay chef yeah man man he was a chef
John lots of chefs and food we wouldn't
die without because I'm a honestly we
would die without food and if and we
would die like that's why would I will
just a quick recipe for the for the fans
out there I'm on the Wonder Bread diet
so I'm doing all bleach process class
just frankfurters and frankfurters four
loaves of 180 i'll do what i ball up I
took of wonder but I ball it up man
that's one big ball that I could den sit
down how do you feel at all times
I feel sluggish on the verge of murder I
am feeling I will on the verge of red
plug is on the verge of murder of on the
verge of of I have sores in the bottom
of my feet that don't heal yeah other
than that I'm good
I do have scurvy like a pirate on a ship
400 years ago because I'm not because I
think to eat fruit is to show weakness
yes
so I do that so I am developing sores
like a pirate and my gums are spongy
that see spongy gums
what does your chin yeah but I also just
will say if you what else you got an egg
I also have gout an awl short rib mac
and cheese you know guys a short rib
free rib sliders and then you know got a
shout out to Koreans short it really
like a Korean short rib can you take a
break from the short rib I did that's
when I moved the Wonder Bread I'm a
goddamn nutritionist yeah okay chop the
chin what do you got some him out nicki
manaj said she was gonna pay Jeffery
Owens $25,000 donate time that's hairy
turns out she hasn't done yet
it's just a publicity stunt well she
says she does want to pay him but then
his team is saying that they're super
easy to reach out to and then she's
saying that they've been trying to reach
out to him and have middle shout out to
him I don't think it's a donate to his
favorite charity okay but i mean i
strange how we're all up in arms about
this guy and how you booked all these
gigs not find a little strange it's a
whole weird like it's a whole weird
Medan name
you know remember that guy that old like
haha that guy's not doing it anymore and
then quickly like don't shame him for
you know done it and then it's like oh
let's give him something so we can we
can feel bit so yeah not like yeah and
I'm sure he's like great I was an actor
I love to work I'll take a [ __ ] gig
you know but then it's like he's on set
and this whole thing and then he just be
he'll like distraction you don't even
like a year so I like back and you know
it'll be it's kind of strange do you
remember him from Cosby Show yeah - yeah
yeah I remember him I mean if I saw him
at the gross drawing back down with sad
story Cosby sure anyway he's making a
living yeah I didn't think he was
[ __ ] scrooge mcduck richlum and
bel-air off that one for now role he
played on the Cosby's now I know and
we'll cuz Cosby all those residuals went
to that one eye that one eye that's
[ __ ] that's interesting that's right
who was on the Wonder Bread that one I
was on a Wonder Bread diet of that thing
was feeling [ __ ] sluggish oh my god
Brendan like cos he looks like a burnt
turtle I did yeah man he looks like a
burnt turtle without a shell man he
looks it's you know it's it's tough and
he's oh my yeah I bro yeah he's blind
though yeah out of that one I know he's
basically blind he's busy he's all oh my
god well that was he that one one that
one went to sleep what's what's the deal
what's gonna happen now oh no he's a
rapist yeah um Cosby I mean oh I was
when's the special coming out one's an
expert coming out I heard net plates off
from a deal yeah I [ __ ] me rape Channel
god dammit he really uh he's one of the
worst that's one of the wart his whole
thing is so careful truly they like
broke my dad's heart
yeah do you don't realize what he meant
to us yeah we need us yeah I get it
though cuz he was like them he was a
symbol of surety yeah it'd be like if
Tim Allen took like for me like Tim
Allen was
dad who like everyone loved but like if
Tim Allen got busted read about him Tim
Allen wasn't the best guy yeah but he
was more than that close the first to
enter tears the best guy and then
there's like Bill Cosby love yeah he was
the first entertainer I think they make
a billion dollars
he was also invincible Thomas also
involved in lots of social charities
like in education drives yeah in the
black community I mean he was he was
America's dad and he was that he was
african-american that just raping
[ __ ] non-stop news man that's what
it's all [ __ ] you know what now that
you say ready P and you look at him he
gives me the heebie jeebie and a temple
to Randy one runner a temple I think a
hurdler or something that's what I think
of when I see him shout out the tracker
field shots everyone's athletic
accomplishment and a Lisa Bonet Oh still
this one a still so beautiful timepiece
yes but back then and I got a shout out
to Jeffery Owens looking good look at
the guy is that his name how about Jamal
it looks great man but I got a traitor
show fetish I got a trader Joe fetish
did I judge or did I say trader show
yeah yeah but it's the same thing Joe
yeah I have a Trader Joe's shoe fetish
thing my thing is the way I get off guys
quickly just to shout out to what I'm
doing as far as how I get off yeah
anyone who works at Trader Joe's they
come into the house they drop their
shoes off I just go and like smell their
Trader Joe's shoes are you sniffing yeah
i school seats yeah and then I know that
I do what I do what do you do your hand
find your pants yeah Nick's jerking off
to smelling shoes yeah yeah
yes darkness and CIA oh yeah cuz that'll
set he'll be set for life after an
apparent sunny no catch that you catch
that Bakula backdraft you know what I
mean this is great what else you had
chin up the Cosby's I'm gonna revival
alright so this is a little bit this is
on Saturdays Naomi Osaka who beats arena
Raylan Williams at the US Open yeah so
she was the first Japanese woman
japanese girl to win it which is making
history there
but then a lot of stuff happened
afterwards you guys know that Sarina got
yeah he's qualified she was crying and
Sarina calm right she was she was fine
and they took points away from all right
yeah
and to find her like she got she got
violet is a violation your coach is not
allowed to say anything to you when
you're playing yeah so she was
sanctioned or warned or something or a
point was taken away from her because
she got coaching from the sideline and
then she's not she goes I'm not getting
coached don't install my character and
then he's and then she said you're a
thief because you stole a point and then
he gave her another point yeah yeah
that's what she lost and then it turns
out her coach was coaching her from the
sidelines
really yeah he admitted it they're all
coaching he dated minute it you know
they're all coaching that's a problem
but she says she didn't hear it I think
that was her thing but it doesn't matter
once it happens it happened I mean it's
crazy for that girl cuz the had been you
like you look at her you're like oh
she's 20 years old Serena's been around
her entire life like he's been playing
and has to be the like truly the model
for everything that she's done and I
think I mean I've heard secondhand that
like her Osaka's father trained her
literally like basically word for word
as to how Serena's dad trained her and
team he was 8 like so she's like oh she
is a prod she is a product of a in a
full product of like the Serena Williams
so this weird thing to beat her and also
have this crazy lady
yeah it's it's not her fault at all
she's just trying to [ __ ] win a
championship by the way though yeah I
just think it's it's also really telling
that Serena was being coached yeah
there's a shout out to Naomi's dad let
me see let me see in a better picture I
can't see her face the fuzzy Wikipedia
yeah I thought she was a half asian half
Japanese
yeah half a patient so she's black and
Japanese war in Japan so that's why sure
yeah okay and okay
yeah okay okay okay it's a mix
I got you that's a mix shoutout to Naomi
Watts a great actress Naomi Watts -
great actress what's and now my Osaka
yeah and Naomi Osaka and for the French
for inventing that name Osaka Oh Naomi
well yeah Bom
friend shout out to the French for their
fries man bring it back bring it pass
speaking of we're in a post-911 it's
9/11 was yesterday let's talk about
freedom fries and french fries again
let's get back let's bring back the
freedom price what we're missing right
now in the nation the freedom fries yeah
we're missing that so this is actually
related to this an Australian newspaper
did this cartoon and some people were
saying it's racist even JK Rowling that
author wrote Harry Potter shout-out to
Harry Potter to the right at Universal
Studios foolish things because this is
the big lips the big nose but you know a
lot of caricatures the exaggerated stuff
right yeah and also Sarina has broad
features yes the cartoon I gotta say man
it's like you look at that like that is
a and then it's you look at it is like a
typical caricature if you saw like if I
saw the Jewish version of that yeah I'd
be like come on bro like and it happens
it's well it reminds me of the the
propaganda cartoon yeah some Nazi German
right so similarly that is like an
old-school throwback like yeah black
native like the girl Naomi they're not
exaggerating her features she's not
small I played Naomi the other woman who
was also of African descent as of white
blond white blond hair so it's like it's
just like it's a little tricky yeah it's
a little tricky but that's what cartoons
are which is to not say that cartoons
are good or bad but it is like it is
literal you know another one it's not a
very flattering face no so after the
controversy the newspaper doubled down
and they did this cover afterwards you
can see it welcome to peace here oh yeah
and they do they did Trump you know I
respect them for doubling down I'm gonna
be honest I don't agree with it but I
at least double down I like now they're
like you know what [ __ ] it hey when you
guys shout out the PC we shout out to PC
world Patou shout out to shout to the
herald-sun shout out to PC Richards yes
shout out to the shout out to PC
computers yeah yep yeah honestly showing
you have to be careful when it comes to
satire and being humorous people but if
you've got people like kind of watching
everything you're doing accusing you of
everything it's pretty dangerous
territory I I agree
dude how about nor McDonald dude would
know that way your Caravan now
shoutout to chin for not knowing what's
going on in the wound or what horn
McDonald defended louis c.k
he got so much backlash she's supposed
to be on Jimmy Fallon last night they
cancelled his apparent really and what
he said really wasn't terrible he's
defending louis ck n rose and egos hold
up I've been friends with him for 25
years
yeah shout-out to no one known the story
I know I didn't have a no clue and no
one did
well except you well that depresses the
economy story literally it's all we
talked to her last night you guys where
were you bro I was honestly I wasn't the
[ __ ] factory man working for Jamie no
kidding I wasn't but I was thinking
might in my head I was like if I it
turns out that I was moonlighting is
Jamie's Jamie Masada's assistant at
night Jamie Jamie problem yeah I'm just
I'm not a versatile stuff yeah I'm
bouquets booked in the show I'm just
taking care of Jamie's personal personal
assistants yeah yeah like try cleaning
yes I did by day by day yeah I was like
I'm his buddy Wrangler I hold a bunch of
his buddies that he can use throughout
the day but what did he say there what
did he say verse 6 overcome he couldn't
be on minutes before they're set to take
white what was it The Hollywood Reporter
he's talking about the victims dancer
would say bass ever sexually be talked
about I see you both of whom lost
adjuster racial remarks a chain may be
googled nor McDonald's
comments or something like that yeah man
I was there look it's it's not the
interview down Howard Stern this was not
Howard Stern he did this today oh he did
this today well the Howard Stern cuz
this is Hollywood Reporter interview
sparks country there you go yeah that'll
have it chin let's just do this one here
you can't be nuanced about this you got
to be 100% on board in every way or you
lose your job that's interesting it's
tricky because it's like the fight you
guys are both in you're masturbating in
front of me and I haven't said yeah I
said it work I've just let it
no one's force should be here bro bro
sort of that and that's gonna get rocky
you might get wet a shout-out to he said
he's glad it's so this way said he's
referring to the me to moment yet he
said he's got slowed down a little he
said how deeply sorry feels for people
with face consequences after admitting
wrongdoing in their action statements
he's specifically talking about Louie CK
and Roseanne Barr having gone through
what they have losing everything in a
day yup said he really doesn't think
Donald Trump's presidency has been that
disastrous so he's not defending Louie
CK he said you didn't like seeing a
friend of his yeah that's what you said
but that made him somehow losers i man
who the problem is that you didn't say
that much there are consequences from
saying anything and and I think that's
norms I mean right so another event
saying that Annabelle Ron Jimmy is still
significant or what sucks is that's a
huge group this movement has some sort
of control they didn't make that big of
a difference and I thought it's very yes
and III think that's why I say I think
when they do this stuff the me to
message is losing its power you think
someone's taking it seriously it's like
all right if anyone says anything up
there's ramifications so when there's
real problems you guys wanna bring that
to light you've been crying about all
this my new stuff you're ruining what
the real message is and he got in
trouble goes to be maligned for quote
unquote humanizing Trump funny I thought
it was a human if you have the nominated
president on your show and he's your guy
that's why I was Fallon because he's
because he's basically like Fallon had
Trump on the show right
if your MBC tear like deal we don't need
this [ __ ] oh yeah you get it
I think it's cowardly of The Tonight
Show not to have him on I really do I
think it's [ __ ] yeah I mean I just
do so you can't really express yourself
unless you're towing me as a comic you
can but not anymore well you can't get
like a normal adult sale ticket sales
aren't gonna be affected by him not
being you know when you're doing shows
now out and about do you feel like more
conscious of what you're saying or
anything no I mean I just try to tell
the truth how I feel right so so for me
I think I'm a fair-minded person so I
don't worry about right I'm more
conscious because I like I don't know
I'm more conscious yeah I I'm for for
the first time ever I'm more conscious
like even last night I start gonna Rogen
sugar about it of this bit oh my god
should I say this like the [ __ ] you
talking about yes I'm like dude why I'm
worried cuz I work for this network now
I don't
and he's like definitely don't do that
because for me like I'm my last special
I just finished editing yesterday and
it's great by the way thank you my
[ __ ] love she'll love it
he's watched it four times I can't
believe you watch that many times you
know you know what my heart you quoting
my jokes back and I'm on a screen saver
which is exciting
thanks Nick and I might Cal I'm calling
oh that's my favorite client Nick Kroll
I'm gonna call my special Nick Kroll
that's [ __ ] actually very kind of you
hey and but but there are some things in
it where I was talking about and I had
that thought but I was like if I'm gonna
start if I'm as long as I'm telling the
truth of how I see things I may pay a
consequence but I don't think I ever
really go wrong Tommy should be censored
because you're not forcing on anyone no
and I would choose to be the least alert
kind of I do feel like there's a if I
can't I can't say what I want anymore
it's like no you could say what you want
as long as you I think as long as you
have a point of view about whatever it
is you're saying yeah that it's not just
smart days are the gone good days of the
gun days the gun days are the gunshot
days of our lives is a shout-out to Days
of Our Lives shut up too
a hospital some of the days of fury days
days at the Conner what days are the gun
our movies like Days of Thunder shout
out when I was looking for Jerry
Bruckheimer shout out to don symphony
yes shut up - TC bringing the heat every
[ __ ] move everything out - Tom Cruise
shadow on Scientology for real oh I was
just saying that I was like truth
honestly if that's what Scientology is
where it's like you can [ __ ] jump and
run and [ __ ] land on another building
or shadow or Scientology yeah learn to
fly goddamn helicopter nod - I want in
shut up the Dianetics shoutout to l ron
hubbard shoutout shot going clear
shoutout to going clear shout out to
every powell event John Travolta sound
off - no sugar shadow
Bucky gone so I've gone are the days
when you could say something that could
be funny but let's say irresponsible
yeah like yeah you have to if you're
gonna you can still go - I think you can
still get away with basically any point
of view as long as it's like as it's
funny and it has it has a point of view
that it's not a not lazy it's not lazy
that's the things I just think gone are
the days of like lazy like homophobic
racist anti-woman stuff I think if you
have ways of making similar versions of
points about whatever it is that your
your take is you just can't be lazy
about or or mean-spirited like I heard
last night then this guy is one the nice
people I know and he dropped the f-word
not [ __ ] but an egg yeah and even I was
like oh brother I would [ __ ] I would I
want to go there yeah it's like is it
need for it like I feel like you could
do put insert something else there and I
feel like you'd be a bigger bag if
you're saying that but you got one of
those words whatever those trigger words
are if you're saying them you better
have liked it yeah there has to be
something to be fortified
yeah it just needs to be purposeful yeah
you see these days yeah especially these
days which is it has changed things
around a little bit but it's also just
like you gotta be [ __ ] I don't know
like cuz I agree it's like you go to a
club you see every point of view and
even for the most part like that's funny
man
and yeah and the audience isn't the
audience is like I never yeah it's like
if you got good people or professional
what they're doing it's just like you
don't want other people handle and
[ __ ] like motorized saws who don't
know how to use it yeah yeah I'll cut
off someone's fat I do think though that
now I do think that there there might be
there might be a sort of a the people
making decisions in certain that yeah
yeah are looking for a particular point
of view yes well but I only feel that
way if you're not if you're not
established I think like the the the the
big time comics the the guys the pros
pros they can still do what they're
doing
yeah no not gonna be shunned or and
those networks are right and dying with
them I think if you if you don't have a
perspective and you you're not known for
that and they're trying to do that
you're not gonna get picked up on these
big networks yeah shout it to all the
big networks and shout out to the
streaming services as well especially
shot the CBS shuttle s no whoa shout out
to less of the behavior yes he's in some
trouble
this is funny how you can be on the top
of a pyramid those mother if you just
have a payoff of a hundred million yeah
I got fight with sharing that's what I
carry redstone yes and you wonder if she
called Ronan Farrow and said you know
yeah wrote in that first articles
run-ins like they're in a dispute this
is not about that but I'm sure all those
people are happy to I think Sherri red
sunny the Redstone family was more than
happy to see unfollowed what was
unfolding and I'm sure that they were
shout out to his life for staying on the
networking hosting two shells really
chance could of what she does yeah shout
out to all types of program reality
program shout out to the talk talk shout
out to the talk with Julie Chan and
Sharon Osbourne yes
I don't like Sharon Ozma you know what
sure enough I saw her treat somebody
badly really what'd she do a store clerk
really well were you at the store you're
at the hustler store I saw it how would
you do is in Vegas at John Varvatos we
guys buying drugs what happened I saw
her treat the guy who badly very badly
oh that's a bummer like what did she do
with my own eyes and I heard everything
what'd she do baby I I don't know if I'm
allowed to say I don't want to let me
check with ya she doesn't live wishes
but she the way she behaved was way she
behaved I'd imagine a job available I
can explain 70 black Jerry have him not
asking for ID when she presented her
should who cry know the [ __ ] I am and
and he said and she said go [ __ ]
yourself and walked out uh and I talked
to the guy and I go did she just tell
you to go [ __ ] yourself cuz she just
told her a system that's what she said
huh this is the general thing of what I
allegedly um I saw enough to sit to
realize who she is when the cameras are
not on yeah and I believe she's a shitty
person
yeah and that was a John Varvatos to
John Varvatos I have to dress in rock
stars and Howard Stern and Brian got
Helen four-year and he came down from
the CLI you think from there Brian on
ropes did you find out of my store [ __ ]
I have trouble buying let me add a
jumper of eight is where I'm like I
don't know if I want to spend like six
hundred ollars I'm boots yeah yeah
that's Brennan shop not me yeah I went
mmm these are expensive boots yeah and
they look like they're gonna last about
a minute no no John Bay's make some good
[ __ ] make some good I love his clothing
shot the Nick Joe so expensive the
blazer blazer that's my thing he knows
that sting almost like you get what you
pay for
yeah I know but to style it'll I have
nope all of those play I was going
somewhere [ __ ] fancy I can't do like
I do every now and again yeah and I was
going to the Shakey's and crash kids
birthday so I wanna be dressed up okay
so but I was like I'm gonna go to the
Beverly Beverly Center yeah have you
guys been to the Beverly sure - recently
they're redoing a lot of construction
have breed there there's a lot of
construction that Beverly's yeah PF
Changs holden [ __ ] solid ground for
yep care but I'm like I'm going I was
going to can and I'm like I wanna go I'm
gonna can Film Festival I want to look
[ __ ] sharp sure so I go into that
store and I'm like I'm gonna go into one
of these
stores like you're like Esau Iran like a
Gucci all of those places be like I'm
gonna you're gonna trust European I'm
gonna buy yeah I'm gonna go to Europe
and I got and I'm doing I'm gonna go buy
[ __ ] stuff that's like let me feel
European that I'm like a fancy rich
European yeah and I could I couldn't
bring myself to buy right well like I
could I bought I bought something
eventually but it was a jacket you know
from Prada that was reversible yeah so I
could justify that I was like because
you are spending when you go to Gucci
furlong you'll know better than I do but
spending five six grand is not a problem
no it's and it's for a jacket yeah I
don't know man I guess I'm finding this
like Chinese bomber jacket it's like
silk Chinese bomber jacket we're like
$2,900 they're gonna do this [ __ ]
alright I guess I'm doing you know and I
just like couldn't and I'm like that I
like money have you always been like
that
I mean I like nice [ __ ] I buy nice shake
good money I've made good money I come
from money like it's like I get you know
what I'm you know like not pretending on
my drive a nice car I do now
what car I got a Tesla me too I [ __ ]
love it I've never cared about a car at
my life that's in every world you you
know like it so you want to challenge
your what do you got a Porsche Cayenne
he does have one of those but that's
from this gt3 chin if you're holding it
up for God's sakes or no Porsches bro
yeah well you being a car guy so yeah
that's what he drive that's [ __ ] rad
see the one with the fin yeah he's got
gold rims and it's purple oh that's
great that's what this idiot try you
live your goddamn Donecker
it's a legal racecar and it's his only
car I do respect that it's his primary
and only car that's his drive around car
dude that's Brandon shots on shop right
now making gold ruin a fast and furious
life and Nova mineral a pee brew I live
my lighter 1/4 mile at a time right
shout-out to Pablo Vin Diesel and Pablo
and how much he loves and yes Pablo
shoutout to VIN shut up - Vinnie
shoutout to that thing does nothing for
you look at that there's nothing
gorgeous thanks - that's it goddamn pair
of soccer shorts from the late 90s
that's Yeah right like it's like RuPaul
was a car I love it yes love it but I
gotta say so I've never cared about a
car but I got the Tesla and it is so
great nice you drive an iPad yeah yeah
man but right it's like it's so fast and
smooth and the voice [ __ ] like because I
don't care about I want to get in the
car be like navigate that I say it out
loud it's [ __ ] on the screen I'm done
and then it's nice and I go past people
and then I everyone so I'll put on that
little auto drive yes when you're in
traffic you just [ __ ] sit there and
it's lightful you tell my abs I tape
sighs [ __ ] not on take naps I go to
sleep yes you you have the regular of
the regular and you of the SUV yeah my
next one might be the SUV though I don't
know dude you never know unless you visa
nice because you can fully put the seat
back and just bed stuy cruz i like the
wings on the yeah I'm not Tesla guy yet
though it's it I'm enjoying it but I'm
bumming out kicks and kicks it's a great
car do you get do you think you get
pulled over do you get pulled over in
your car never really know most cops
give me thumbs up drives he drives out I
went a hundred 40 miles an hour on 405
and I cop strolled up to me and just
went like this really yep yeah let's
race respecting you I'm a suspect
yeah say some pretty good job now I
don't know about these goings I don't
know I see I kind of like that I like
them but I'm like I'm picking my driver
I wouldn't take how my driveway is
configured because I got I got the
I got the g-force on each side yeah you
fly private my parking lot is my round
you must have a lot of money I can't
spin that money Gucci but maybe for it's
this you know hey Wonder Bread the
tingling g-forces you got to pay you're
paying that staff full time eat when
you're not flying out Oh Holies bro you
know I know a guy you use your busiest
[ __ ] you guy who does vacations and
stuff whether I not really mean I go to
I went to Burning Man how was that
[ __ ] loved it well you were to love
it man
you go the group now what with a buddy
and then we kind of get mobbed though I
feel I could get my there's moments
where it'd be a little tricky in the I
had a big silly hat and I [ __ ] kiss
you get dress up and then the currency
there is basically yeah everybody's
dressed there's no money there's no
money it's experience I love how they're
like no money but it's expensive miss
[ __ ] if you do it right well it's you
know like I rented an RV here drove it
up there yeah and it was unbelievable
I've never seen anything like it in my
life and that's what it is you can be
part everywhere people are there's crazy
clubs everywhere and there it's
unbelievable I've never and then they
burn the man they burn like a huge man
everyone comes and every like 70,000
people roll up and it's [ __ ] enough
they've learned that man Bowl right here
so I went in that temple that temple is
another building and people put like
memories of loved ones in there I'm
going there it's a very solemn place
it's very emotional it's pretty it's
really kind of amazingly emotional it's
nothing the whole [ __ ] thing in the
last a lot of drugs right Nick there's a
lot of drugs there now when I say no
one's sober Brian I mean nobody's over
yes nick is a huge drug I do about it I
do about a kilo of cocaine and cocaine
are both bad shout out to the white
bread and Molly died Burning Man
shout out what I'll do is I'll what I'll
do is I'll do it I'll do a Wonder Bread
I'll do two lows you need.if for the
kids at home ok ok it's two loaves of
Wonder Bread you you squeeze it out into
a pie like a pie pie crust yeah then you
do a layer
of Mali oh boy this all MDMA ecstasy
whatever sort of that version of it is
that and it's like a pills and it that
acts like a rhubarb dude you caramelize
that mala it's a lot of Molly then you
do strips of I mean whatever you want to
do ketamine dude and then you've just it
after the end with like you know cocaine
heroin and then here's what people
forget here's what people forget to do
at the last stage is just the opioids
okay to say don't I don't know if
Nikki's right about all that you just
how long were you at Burning Man I was
there like five or six days a long time
where do you stay I said rvi weed I
rented an RV and drove it up there it's
expensive to get into the space a lot
[ __ ] that goes on right there are
orgy rooms it's weird
booth our boy Aubrey goes yeah it's it's
there is sexual stuff and then there is
Pete but a lot of the people there are
I'm only going there Gus pressing up and
hanging out there's so much going on
yeah that you're like you're almost like
cool like it'd be cool to get laid but
like you're like sure I think I'll maybe
go to that saloon in the middle that
doesn't get my dick sucked yeah or like
yeah it's crazy man it's and truly
unlike anything I've ever I do want to
experience it just for this what is that
that's amazing well they're the whole
middle of the thing it's a scene out of
Star Wars yeah and and it's like
everybody's biking around and there's
huge installation art pieces around
everything is so big is it kind of cool
yeah I'll never go but that's all you're
too old for it well he'd be the oldest
one there twelve yeah I'm told yet lost
in the sand oh you died of dehydration
yeah lots in the sand oh you know you
don't think your skin can tolerate the
LA weather oh man I saw Tim Conway there
who was on Carol Burnett yeah yeah he
was the market income at those girls
dude them all to beautiful women so
truly I've never seen such a collection
you don't have Halloween's kind of a
freedom pass for groups just like [ __ ]
yeah well this is a hole not this is
that on Moloch at those curls there it's
really beautiful there are crazy
beautiful people there I feel like but I
feel like we would have the best time
ever there nam its it's a great it's a
great hey guys what you doing huh come
here and I'd kind of any room in that
Jeep for me yeah you know I had a pie I
truly I mean it's but it's and it's very
like it is there's it's a real hippie
dippie real warm vibe you know there's
like a spiritual element to it all
nobody wielding much at this much of
this I don't know there are no people
will do much at this shout out to
Burning Man
shout out to drugs in general and shout
out the same I'm gonna get into
psychedelics actually dude you know what
I mean yeah boom Nick crawl yeah you're
coming out right yeah dude October fifth
Netflix
nope not children you said the fifteenth
earlier oh [ __ ] correcting me on October
if you don't listen but for a legit
you'll die if you don't know big mouth
it's then - then [ __ ] you it then [ __ ]
you and and no shout-out to you Jesus to
it yeah don't you turn on I'm gonna turn
on everybody just listen this whole
thing please do look I burp shout out to
burning bridges Nick you're going bad on
everybody like that [ __ ] you guys [ __ ]
your show [ __ ] your fans no man [ __ ]
this whole thing that [ __ ] water bike
is getting to his head now so I can
shout out to burning bridges [ __ ] all
you [ __ ] all of it Nick yeah October 5th
pack Netflix we love big mouth Nick
Kroll everybody Nick Kroll this is the
finally kid we're out